well today marks the start of black
history month all month long we will be
sharing stories about important
uh contributions of local black leaders
and
families we start at the neon museum
where rocky theis is there with more on
their exhibits on sites with deep roots
in both las vegas
and black history rocky
thank you so much christian before we
get to the black history month i want to
talk to don
vice president of the neon museum we
were standing here and trying to figure
out where to stand so you guys do have
social distancing
how they can come visit safely well we
wipe down everything we take your
temperature when you arrive
and we have these lovely little stickers
that tell you exactly how far apart you
are so
you can move away if you feel like
you're too close to someone and
obviously we are in the great outdoors
so it's very safe if you guys come get
out here get some fresh air and get a
history lesson
that's right get a history lesson let's
talk black history we're here at our
next
next sign this one is kind of hard to
see but it says silver slipper
and this was a site in 1950 of an event
hosted by the n-double
naacp for black history month what makes
this significant is at that time
you could not rent a room downtown or on
the strip to host a black event so
this was one of the first man these
stories are not getting i mean
i'm really enjoying this guys if you're
not noticing so let's move on now
to last but certainly not least this is
really special this is actually in
the neon museum's logo so yes introduce
us this is our logo but it's also the
lacancha
paul revere williams designed this this
facility
um it's the 60th anniversary of the la
concha this year and february is prw's
birthday so
a better reason to come but you'll see
it shaped like a shell
when you come to the museum to pay us a
visit you're going to enter a building
that looks just like this on the outside
and so we want you to come down you can
go to www.neonmuseum.org to buy tickets
you can come on a guided tour you can
come and just walk around by yourself
or you can get a combo and see a guided
tour and our other experience called
brilliant
and what we were thinking don and what
we were talking about earlier before the
shot here
is that this is the perfect time to come
down because you kind of get that
golden hour plus night time right this
is amazing because
you can see the outline of the signs as
well as the lights that are on them
and it's beautiful at night as well but
you see mostly the lights you don't see
the outline of the signs but
anytime's a good time to come down to
come down anytime is a great time to
celebrate black history as well so come
on down to the neon museum
thank you so much don this was really
special come back again
i will thank you i'll turn back to you
guys thank you so much rocky one of my
favorite spots there well the city of
las vegas has also announced
several events for black history month
there will be an exhibit at city hall
through april 14
february 16th and 17th there is a
two-day virtual conference
with national speakers about engaging
young men of color
and there is also an essay and picture
contest for students we have more
information on these events and others
this month on eight newsnow com